here now with more reaction Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter Florida
Congressman Byron Donalds Congressman
your reaction to the U.S Supreme Court
decision
um to keep title 42 in place is it going
to make any difference really
well first of all it's a good decision
to have because it'll frankly keep an
avalanche of people seeking Asylum
illegally by mind you they're seeking
Asylum at an illegal point of entry
which is actually against a federal law
that allowed to do that but Joe Biden is
doing it anyway so it's a reprieve on
these border these border towns and
border states and all the resources that
are that need to be done but the real
problem is not title 42 the real problem
is Joe Biden reversed course after he
was inaugurated because he didn't want
to manage the border the way Donald
Trump had managed to border I.E he
didn't want it to he didn't want to
manage it successfully he wanted It Wide
Open Southern border to allow migrants
and illegal immigrants to come into the
United States ad nauseum this is the
plan from the white house so I'm glad
that the Supreme Court is holding up
title 42 for now while they heal while
they hear the full case but what the
Supreme Court needs to understand is
that Joe Biden is not following
immigration law on purpose because he
and the Democrats want in wide open
border here in the United States Sarah
um you've spent more time at the border
than anybody I know of your Intrepid
work has really been admirable
um and you know you're kind of the Lone
Ranger down there for the last couple of
years uh you know NBC ABC CBS that was
toxic we don't go down there where you
know we're BFF with Joe and so we can't
cover his biggest crisis
um now all of a sudden because of title
42 they just say well let's go take a
look see and they're shocked shocked
that there's gambling going on down here
and a whole lot more uh You Gotta Laugh
at these Knuckleheads right
well Greg yeah you're right look this is
I've been covering the Border actually
for almost 20 years I started on the
border in the early 2000s I've never
seen it quite like this this is unheard
of what we're seeing and we were
reporting on it you're right Greg I was
down at the border I was saying hey look
look at what's going on we have other
colleagues like Bill malusian and others
from Fox News that are down there also
showing what's going on at the border
and when you think about it this is an
open sieve that is not only harming the
American people the National Security of
our nation Greg when we see an influx
not only of migrants that aren't being
vetted there are so many young people
being trafficked into the United States
by these cartels and I was just in
Mexico City I visited two shelters where
children had been rescued from Human
traffickers some as young as six years
old were being trafficked by these
Predators for unimaginable things I
don't even want to talk about them on
television Vision with you right now
because it's horrific you can't even
imagine what they've been through and
here we have a government that leaves
the Border wide open wide open and the
only people benefiting from this other
than them I think because there has to
be a reason why the Biden Administration
is not abiding by the law or allowing
our federal law enforcement to abide by
the law but are the human traffickers
and the drug cartels in Mexico who is
going to stand up to them who is going
to protect our children from the
Fentanyl and who is going to protect the
children and the people being trafficked
into our country right this is no longer
just numbers this is about human beings
people that are literally losing their
lives well and I'm glad I think that's
what's so frustrating I'm glad I'm so
very glad Sarah that you brought up the
fentanyl because I want to ask you about
that Congressman Donald's according to
the CDC
uh a hundred thousand overdose fentanyl
synthetic drug deaths all of it coming
from the border in these cartels
so a hundred thousand a year
that's
275 people per day who are being
murdered by these illegal drugs coming
across our Southern border and Joe Biden
won't even bother to go to the border to
see the crisis that his incompetence has
created what would you say to him about
that
well first of all to the president I
know he doesn't care because he doesn't
bother to go it's outrageous Americans
are losing their lives you haven't even
visited the Border not once the news
media I'm gonna go back Saturday I want
to talk about it I will there are young
girls who are being raped by the cartels
and the coyotes in the journey to our
Southern border that's happening right
now but number two back to Joe Biden he
don't care about this he wants this
policy and the news media that's down
there covering her and covering it now
where were they two months ago during
the elections nowhere to be found but
they're there now to cover their butts
it's a joke and it's disgusting and Joe
Biden has the authority to change it and
he won't because he's following his
radical Democrat policy listen this is
awful for the people who are going to
lose their lives it is awful for the
people who overdose and the families
that have to deal with it but for the
families in America who have to deal
with this problem first and foremost
look no further than the president of
the United States he doesn't care about
protecting you he only cares a about his
political agenda that's why he won't go
to the Border that's why he doesn't
answer questions that's why the media
won't bother asking him and that's why
in this Omnibus Bill that they just
passed they've refused to have the money
go to actually secure the Border it's
ridiculous Congressman Donalds thank you
for being so candid sure Carter as
always your outstanding reporter
reporting at the border uh has really
been important to us so thank you for
that as well hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else